j'ai décidé de rendre obligatoire
l'école maternelle et incident à l'essai
de 6 à 3 ans en france l'obligation
d'instruction dès la rentrée 2010 9
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important ça
s'inscrit dans une lignée historique
c'est la quatrième fois que
l'instruction obligatoire évolue par les
textes par un texte de loi portée par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer
le projet de loi écoles de la confiance
réalise un engagement du président de la
république sur le papier l'instruction
obligatoire à 3 ans fait l'unanimité
mais dans les faits son application pose
question financer les écoles maternelles
privées
c'est tout simplement financer la
concurrence de l'école publique avec des
fonds publics alors que l'école publique
elle elle accueille tous les enfants
l'instruction à 3 ans soulève la
question du financement de l'école
maternelle et relance une controverse
entre l'école privée l'école publique
il est d'abord été tranchée par le
parlement depuis de 59 par la société
depuis dans 1 59
moi je n'ai aucune envie de relancer la
guerre scolaire source d'inquiétude pour
les élus locaux entorse à l'école
publique d'après les syndicats avancée
historique selon le gouvernement la loi
école fait débat
ouais
[Musique]
à être 2000 habitants au pied des
pyrénées
comme partout au pays basque l'école
publique côtoient l'église du village
[Musique]
philippe elissalde est maire depuis 2011
puis le connais il est même dommage la
télé la pomme dans ce lieu sont
regroupés en même temps une crèche
l'école maternelle l'école élémentaire
le centre loisirs sans hébergement et
même des activités autour du milieu
associatif
l'établissement accueille 170 enfants de
la petite section de maternelle jusqu'au
cm2 pour philippe elissalde le village
ne peut pas vivre sans son école le
coeur et le poumon cevital c'est tout
simplement vital c'est essentiel à la
dynamique et villageoises parce que
l'école de son enfance est toujours
l'école dans leur lesquels on revient
dans laquelle on a constitué ses amis
comme dans beaucoup d'autres communes
tous les enfants de 3 ans vont déjà
l'école maternelle sur notre village
c'est pratiquement à 100% je crois que
ça va être
99 8% les enfants de trois ans qui sont
scolarisés
il ya pas de changement en venir de
bouaké concernant les anticipations nous
aurions pu faire tout ce qui existe déjà
dans les écoles au village l'école à 3
ans ne va pas bousculer les habitudes
pourtant la loi suscite des inquiétudes
le sénateur max brisson rapporteur du
projet de loi au sénat est venu faire de
la pédagogie dans son département sur
l'origine humaine du projet de loi
interrogé dans notre groupe
tout al'air juliel l'obligation mobile
fait sous destruction à 3 or hélas il
avait fait la société a été plus vite
que la loi
philippe elissalde s'interroge sur la
nécessité d'inscrire dans la loi ce qui
est déjà une réalité
à quoi ça va servir de faire une loi qui
grave dans le marbre trois ans une
structure migratoires à 3 alors que 90
ya dix huit propre sort dix femmes trois
ans sur ce territoire sont déjà
scolarisés
ce qui dérange cet élu c'est que la loi
blanc caire a aussi une conséquence
financière pour les communes en rendant
l'école obligatoire à 3 ans elle les
oblige à subventionner les écoles
maternelles privées
le financement public doit aller à
l'école publique et c'est pour moi un
principe important
à partir du moment où je reçois la
télévision publique
mais on reçoit télévision publique ici
en veut canal+ en le paye ça veut pas
dire que le programme est meilleur mais
qui correspond peut-être davantage à ce
qu'on a envie de voir
mais pour l'école ça devrait pareil le
service public d'éducation il est mené
par l'école publique qui est aussi menée
par l'école sous contrat d'association
et la loi est la loi la matière est très
très très clair c'est un vieux débat qui
refait surface
il porte sur le financement de l'école
privée en france
pour le comprendre il faut remonter à
une loi qui a fait date
la loi debré de 1959 jusqu'au dernier
moment les enfants n'ont pas cru cela
possible
les faire rentrer en classe quand l'été
n'est pas fini pour mettre un terme à la
guerre scolaire qui oppose les
défenseurs de l'école laïque et les
partisans de l'enseignement catholique
la loi debré propose à l'école privée de
passer un contrat avec l'état
l'enseignement privé s'engage à
respecter la neutralité des programmes
et accepter tous les enfants sans
distinction de croyance
en échange ces professeurs sont payés
par l'état
on parle désormais d'enseignement privé
sous contrat
quant aux communes elles doivent financé
à parité les dépenses de fonctionnement
des écoles publiques et des écoles
privées sur leur territoire une
obligation qui ne concernait jusqu'à
présent que l'école élémentaire mais en
abaissant de 6 à 3 ans l'âge de
l'instruction obligatoire
le gouvernement étant cette obligation
de financement aux écoles maternelles
privées sous contrat qui pourront
désormais prétendre aux mêmes
financements que les maternelles
publiques
le contrat d'association permet d'un
côté la reconnaissance de la liberté
d'enseignement et de l'autre la
participation à l'éducation nationale de
des établissements d'enseignement privés
d'un côté les établissements scolaires
s'engagent à se conformer au programme
de l'enseignement public et il s'engage
à accueillir tous les élèves sans
distinction et de l'autre l'état prend
en charge le salaire des enseignants et
les collectivités territoriales prennent
en charge le veut les frais de
fonctionnement des établissements
c'est la reconnaissance de la
participation de l'enseignement privé à
l'oeuvre d'éducation la république une
reconnaissance du privé que la loi
bancaire étant désormais à la maternelle
synonyme aussi d'une dépense nouvelle
pour les communes que l'état veut en
partie compensé mais en partie seulement
les deux tiers des communes de france
verse une des financements aux écoles
maternelles installés sur le territoire
aux écoles maternelles privées sous
contrat une subvention jusqu'à présent
facultative en général inférieur à celle
versée aux maternelles publiques avec la
loi la subvention devra s'aligner sur le
public et donc augmenter or le
gouvernement ne prévoit pas de compenser
la différence de communes qui jeta
présent finançait à 0 et qui sera obligé
financer à 100 ne sera compensé à 100
une commune qui faire c'est cette grotte
elle devra passer à 100 elle sera qu
elle ne sera pas compensé une photo
qu'elle soit compensée à 50
en d'autres termes la loi bancaire
prévoit en l'état de ne rembourser que
les communes qui jusqu'à présent ne
verser rien aux maternelles privées
le sénat veut y remédier
[Musique]
la commission de la culture se réunit
pour examiner le projet de loi les
confiance puisque le mot rigueur de la
loi
le rapporteur métaux voient un
amendement prévoyant la compensation des
communes qui subventionnait déjà les
maternelles privées
il s'agit d'un principe que ces communes
ne vont pas aucune compensation quand
celles qui refusaient de payer sont
également encore les sénateurs adoptent
la maman à une large majorité
nous souhaitons que les communes
c'est-à-dire les deux tiers d'entre
elles en france qui déjà assure une des
dépenses en faveur des écoles
maternelles privées soient elles aussi
compenser ce serait quand même pas tout
à fait normal que seules les communes
qui jusqu'à présent ne donnait rien aux
écoles maternelles privées parce qu'elle
n'avait pas reconnu le contrat
d'association que ces communes là soient
compensées et que celle qui faisait un
effort ne soit pas nous serons très
attentifs à cette question de la
compensation pour les couples
[Musique]
brest subventionne déjà ces écoles
maternelles privées
mais la ville mène surtout une politique
volontariste en direction de l'école
publique
son premier poste de dépense
[Musique]
l'accueil la sortie de questions bon on
peut échanger sur des tas de choses des
fous trigano flottant l'école penhars
très hâte est classé en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire
c'est la plus grande école du finistère
dans la classe passerelle on accueille
même les enfants dès 2 ans pour
s'occuper de ses dix-huit élèves
audrey poirier l'enseignante est
entourée d'une éducatrice spécialisée
ainsi que d'une atsem une assistante
rémunérés par la ville avec des enfants
qui n'ont jamais fréquenté la
collectivité ou qui ont toujours été
gardé leur mère en l'occurrence etc des
enfants pour lesquels on imagine que les
premiers pas à l'école seront seront un
peu difficile donc mais les attentats y
progressivement jusqu'à va être vraiment
très autonome et dans une autre
les parents peuvent accompagner leurs
enfants dans la classe en intégrant les
parents ça leur permet de se sentir à
l'aise d'avoir confiance dans l'école et
qu'après dans les classes suivantes ils
peuvent plus facilement discuter avec
les enseignants et participer davantage
aussi à la vie de l'école
monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit d'activités c'était mieux hier
dans la classe d'à côté elisabeth
couloigner enseigne aux petites sections
de choses très bien portant dans le
langage et la socialisation dans le
langage vous avez vu des plus de six
essais c'est aussi communiquer dans les
ateliers en creux brest consacre 1800
euros par an à chaque enfant en
maternelle publique environ le double de
la moyenne nationale la mairie
subventionne les maternelles privées à
hauteur de 750 euros par élève et par an
avec la loi elle devra donner la même
chose au privé qu'au public c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on participe aux
maternelles privées hauteur de 1 million
cent à peu près demain avec la réforme
on devra donner un peu près deux
millions sept donc ce qui nous fait un
coup supplémentaire d'un million 6 pour
mille cinq cents élèves mais pas un
enfant de plus puisque la plupart des
enfants sont scolarisés
donc c'est là où ça nous pose question
c'est effectivement pas un enfant
supplémentaire puisque la plupart des
enfants sont scolarisés un coût
supplémentaire un million six dans des
collectivités où on a le pack 2 car on
n'a pas droit de dépenser plus donc ça
veut dire que c'est une dépense qui nous
est imposée par une décision de l'état
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas si on va être
compensées puisqu'on est déjà un petit
peu aux maternelles donc voilà
s'imposait ça met vraiment en difficulté
la ville et sur sa politique de l'école
publique
d'autant que la ville n'a pas la main
sur la politique scolaire qu'elle
finance au sein du secteur privé on n'a
aucun regard la ville de brest sur
l'utilisation d'argent public et on
parle de millions par exemple là moi je
vais financer une atsem par classe mais
ils peuvent très bien s'en servir sur de
la communication sur du fonctionnement
je n'ai aucun regard en tant qu'adjointe
de politique éducative qui veut mener
une politique j'ai été élu enfin autre
équipe a été élue pour mener une
politique
je vais donner cet argent à 30% des
enfants sans savoir ce qui est fait
en bretagne l'enseignement catholique
est fortement ancrée environ 40% des
élèves bretons fréquentent une école
privée à ploeuc-sur-lié dans les côtes
d'armor
les parents ont le choix de la
maternelle à la 3e ils peuvent
scolariser leurs enfants dans le public
ou dans le privé
[Musique]
virginie rousseau a choisi l'école
privée
on a vraiment eu un coup de coeur en
fête le pour l'école sainte-anne le
choix s'est révélé un peu comme une
évidence en fait on a été visitée on
devait rappeler la semaine d'après pour
l'autre école et en fait on était
tellement joué qu'eux on a laissé on a
laissé tomber la visite de l'école
publique dès qu'il ya des absences de
professeurs qui peuvent arriver comme
n'importe où un malade ou voilà
tout de suite ils répartissent dans les
autres classes on a la chance d'avoir
des petits effectifs donc c'est plus
facile de pouvoir prendre en charge les
groupes les groupes de classe dans les
autres classes et c'est vrai que voilà
tout tout est fait pour arranger en
général la vie des enfants quoi ce
bâtiment là concerne la classe de cp ce1
une classe de grande section cp au
rez-de-chaussée on va trouver la salle
de motricité et la salle des enseignants
on est arrivés en fait l'école avait
trois classes vraiment des années on a
ouvert une classe en 2011 et une
cinquième place en 2015
nous sommes en contrat d'association
avec la commune moi je suis directrice
depuis 13 ans de cette école et depuis
13 ans bien qu'il ait eu un changement
de mairie l'ogec organisme de gestion
des écoles a toujours touché en fait le
financement de la mairie pour les plus
primaires et pour les maternelles donc
nous avons un forfait en fait par élève
qui est identique en maternelle et en
primaire et l'ordre des réélections de
2014 si je ne me trompe pas le forfait a
été réévalué est indexé sur le coût d'un
élève du public
donc on a même augmenté ce forfait de
manière voilà notre table ans en dix ans
on est passé soixante dix élèves après à
130 donc à pour plusieurs raisons 1
parce que nous avons changé de site et
donc c'est vrai que je pense que les
parents accordent de l'importance
aujourd'hui à l'espace aux locaux et
donc là on a permis de pouvoir
accueillir les enfants dans des locaux
vraiment fonctionnel et accueillant
[Musique]
l'enseignement catholique en france
c'est 2 millions d'élèves soit environ
20% du total des élèves scolarisés dans
notre pays depuis la maternelle jusqu'au
post-bac l'enseignement catholique va
bien si on regarde les effectifs cette
manière de mesurer des choses à nous
sommes en forte croissance des effectifs
depuis dix ans cent mille élèves en dix
ans et une croissance qui était à peu
près répartis partout sur le territoire
national
[Musique]
c'est chez moi ce matin l'attractivité
de l'école privée
ces enseignants brestois la vivent comme
une concurrence ce matin ils préparent
la manifestation contre la réforme de la
fonction publique
mais la loi écoles les mobilise tout
autant ces deux choses pour qu'on me
tende qui a priori en rien à voir mais
c'est vrai qu'au niveau du calendrier
parlementaire est arrivé en même temps
les enseignants ça fait longtemps qu'ils
sont mobilisés tant sur la question de
la réforme des lycées 1 un côté que sur
cette fameuse loi sur l'école de la
confiance qu yves qui pour ne plus me
sur l'école de la défiance laborde rôle
du jour elle est sur la question de la
privatisation
quand tout sera prise et on sera privé
tous des équipes enseignantes elles sont
toujours dans la crainte d'avoir une
école qui faire une classe qui ferme
dans leurs écoles publiques parce que il
y aura une année dix élèves qui sont
partis dans l'école privée
donc on est toujours à se dire d'un
peut-être que en septembre prochain
bon il y aura une fermeture de classe
parce qu'on a tous perdu des élèves donc
on est obligé de le prendre en compte en
fait dans notre fonctionnement de
s'aligner sur le privé qui fait des
portes ouvertes
voilà les dans les écoles publiques ont
fait aussi des portes ouvertes parce que
sinon les enfants les parents ne peuvent
pas choisir l'école et donc voilà on est
dans une consommation de l'école dans un
choix de l'école des parents et auquel
on objet de sa lignée on appelle la
presse quand on fait des sorties
scolaires c'est ont fait de la pub pour
l'école publique on s'est tous regardé
nos élèves les parents sont pas dans une
démarche idéologique sans une démarche
un peu consumériste ça se passe mal avec
le public on va facilement inscrire son
enfant à l'école privée et la réciproque
est vraie aussi d'ailleurs un voilà en
base de l'un à l'autre facilement sans
attachement particulier comme nous on a
pu connaître quand même
on est déjà dans un système à deux
vitesses où l'état nourrit et finance la
la concurrence entre un réseau privé et
le réseau des écoles publique et laïque
donc ça existe déjà ce système à deux
vitesses il est cultivé entretenu
financer il s'étend simplement un peu
plus aux enfants
2 qui fréquentent l'école maternelle
voilà est ce assez pour nous cet art
hogan
certains qui s'exprime de cette façon on
semble vouloir mettre en cause la loi
debré si vous voulez l'enseignement
privé sous contrat participent au
service public c'est quelque chose de
bien établie dans notre système depuis
très longtemps et personne ne songe à
mettre sur leur en question donc je
pense que c'est ça vient souvent l'appui
de discours politiques qui sont faits
pour critiquer la loi alors même qu'elle
est une énorme avancée sociale une
avancée sociale pour le ministre un coup
de pouce à l'école privée pour les
syndicats qui donnent de la voix une
dernière fois alors que débute l'examen
du texte au sénat
savez vous combien enfants étaient déjà
scolarisés au moment des lois jules
ferry des années 1880 oui je vois que
plusieurs sénateurs savent c'est 93 %
des enfants étaient déjà scolarisés et
nous vivons aujourd'hui cette loi
ferry comme étant fondatrice à juste
titre nous la vivons ainsi pour la
république parce que l'objectif il était
évidemment quantitatif parce que là
aussi c'est des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants qui sont allés à l'école grâce
à cette mesure mais bien aux yeux au
delà de ça ça a posé un cadre et ce
cadre est fondamentale la scolarisation
à trois ans on avait compris c'est un
acte politique de communication fort du
président de la république
il s'y est engagé c'est quelque chose
qui va en tout cas qui coûtera pas trop
cher à l'état me coûtera péter
certainement plus cher aux collectivités
locales
nous nous réjouissons tout de même d'en
arriver là
j'ai donc mais trop voir cet article 2
qui votent pour
et même pas nécessaire de demander qui
votre compte c'est à l'unanimité que
l'article ii est adopté le chauvinisme
le sénat adopte l'abaissement à trois
ans de l'instruction obligatoire mais
très vite le sujet des finances locales
revient sur le tapis
quand même un problème qui est posé par
la question financière des communes qui
jusqu'à présent finances et déjà les
écoles les maternelles privées ya
forcément une injustice a à faire en
sorte que celles qui ont rendu possible
à mesure par des choix qu'elles ont pris
ces dernières années ne soit pas
aujourd'hui non pas remercier ces mêmes
passe à la question mais soient
pénalisés par rapport aux autres qui
n'ont pas fait mieux l'amendement voté
en commission demandant la compensation
à l'euro près de toutes les communes est
adopté par les sénateurs contre l'avis
du ministre entend bien les arguments
inverse je les respecte je sais tout à
fait audible mais je pense que nos
arguments sont très audible aussi c'est
une mesure qui sur le plan financier et
neutre alors qu'elle va permettre à des
communes de pouvoir tout simplement
scolarisés plus plus d'enfants donc ça
je crois que c'est quand même important
de le souligner est par ailleurs ça crée
une dynamique de coopération entre
l'état et les communes autour des enjeux
de l'école maternelle
[Musique]
après l'assemblée nationale la loi
écoles de la confiance ainsi passer
l'étape du sénat
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans est
désormais une réalité dans notre pays
si la mesure fait l'unanimité du point
de vue pédagogique elle a fait resurgir
le débat sur le financement de l'école
privée hérité de la loi debré nous ont
posé la question de justement dans la
loi debré peut-être la remettre à plat
il était peut-être temps parce que la
loi debré s'est donné la même chose au
public au privé
c'est ça veut tout et rien dire
aujourd'hui peut-être on aurait dû
identifier
qu'est-ce qu'on devait donner un peu
plus ce qu'est ce que c'était réellement
le coût d'un enfant publiques et un coup
d'un enfant privé et faire une règle
commune
on est globalement aujourd'hui dans ce
que les uns et les autres à peine d'une
paix scolaire que je crois que personne
n'a d'intérêt à réveiller et si jamais
il y avait des velléités de réveil il
faudrait que l'état s'interroge et les
collectivités territoriales s'interroge
sur le ce que leur coûterait le fait de
devoir scolarisés elle même deux
millions d'élèves de plus
l'instruction a trois en fait redouter
un appel d'air vers un secteur privé qui
a déjà le vent en poupe
mais au delà de ce débat quelles
perspectives
la loi blanquet redessine tel pour
l'école publique de demain j'ai toujours
considéré que tirer le système vers le
haut c'était la première des mesures de
justice sociale en réalité parce que
c'est un bénéficie aux élèves qui n'ont
pas autre chose que l'école dans leur
milieu familial pour compenser la non
excellence qui qui existerait donc on a
besoin de fournir de l'excellence pour
tous et ça commence par l'école
maternelle une belle école maternelle
école de la confiance ou l'enfant
s'épanouit à thiers du vocabulaire et ce
faisant on va bien démarré son cp ce
sont ces idées là qui sont derrière la
loi
alors bien sûr après la loi là des
aspects techniques et là des aspects qui
sont pas faits toujours facile à
comprendre au premier abord c'est trop
facile d'aller s'appuyer là dessus pour
dire qu'elle n'a pas d'importance et
très faux l'avenir le montrera
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
ces évolutions ne nous conviennent pas
elle ne nous paraissent pas répondre aux
défis majeurs de l'école en france c'est
à dire la réduction des inégalités
d'origine sociale dans la réussite
scolaire et l'ouverture de des possibles
pour tous les pour tous les enfants
la loi ne va pas tuer l'école publique
elle ne va pas tuer l'école maternelle
mais ce qu'elle dessine comme évolution
ne nous convient pas ne répond pas il
nous semble au défi essentiel de l'école
[Musique]